Còn cố cố khói đen bốc lên quân của tự hứng của các khói của hệ quân biếp ở Mà Bà Ràn, sau khi
irwan phóng tên lợ đáp trả việc Mỹ phối hợp ít sên tập kích irwan chức đó,
nè là cân cứ đáu vai trò chung tâm trong các hợp động hệ quân của biếp tại vùng việc.
Thìng anh ghi nhận tại thủ đô, Mà Đà Mà của Bà Ràn vào nêm qua cho thấy những cuộc khói lơn bốc
cao từ khu của các cân cứ hệ quân nằm gần đường chân trời thành phố.
Theo các một tiên bà đầu, đám trái xuất phát từ căn cứ hệ quân hỏt động vũ trở,
nơi Mỹ trình khai lực lượng và đáp trụ sợ hãn lỗi năm.
Dên biến sảy ra trong bối cạnh irwan tính hành các đòn đáp trả,
nhanh vào y soran và các mục tiêu của Mỹ tại vùng việc.
Sau các cuộc khuôn kích chức đó của Mỹ và y soran,
hiện cho có thuộc điên chính thức về thiện hại,
hãy thương vong liên quan tính của việc.